[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome to this
last session of the day thank you for
coming here and taking up this time
between you and going to have some fun
over at 18 T Park what we're going to do
today is talk about Spotify journey from
on-premises data centers to Google cloud
platform
I'm Peter mark fair word I'm a Solutions
Architect here at Google speaking with
me today are max who's a colleague of
mine from Google and Ramon and Joe and
Josh who are both from Spotify and I
will let each of those gentlemen
introduce themselves when they come up
to speak the four of us were all part of
a core team that composed of Googlers
and Spotify errs that made this
migration a success and so we're gonna
cover what that was and how we did that
and to do that I'll introduce next
speaker max
[Applause]
around how we executed a multi-day
descent migration to GCP we worked with
over 100 teams in two countries and we
migrated over 1200 services and 20000
data processing jobs the this is a very
active collaboration between Google and
Spotify still so the presentation is
split into four parts we'll start with
an introduction where we cover the
Spotify organization and kind of how it
works but we'll also walk into the
higher-level goals of the migration
itself after that we have two main
chapters and they cover the migration
one is for the user facing services and
the other is for data processing and
after that we have lessons learned
during the migration so a note to you
although this migration the strategy is
very tailored to Spotify both
technically and organizationally so if
you would want to do something like this
yourself it might look very different so
let's kick off the intro and here is
Ramon hi my name is Ramon Fran altra I'm
the program manager for the entire cloud
mode migration it Spotify now before we
start diving into this migration what I
would like to do is take you through the
two main reasons why we want to move to
cloud and the first reason is something
that applies at a global company level
if you think about the amount of effort
it takes to maintain compute storage and
network capacity for a global company
that serves more than 170 million users
that's a sizable amount of work just
think about the amount of work it just
takes to replace the service that you
depreciate over every three years that's
a lot of work to do and if I'm really
honest what we really want to do is
Spotify speed the best music service in
the world and none of that work working
on the data centers actually contributes
directly to that
we'd much rather spend all that focus
attention and energy into becoming the
best music service in the world and
build futures for our customers and our
users and our creators that make it the
best music service so we saw a good
opportunity to take some of that work
towards Google and allow our own
engineers to focus on Spotify specific
actions that's one thing but the second
thing is and that helps with choosing a
cloud is that if you start analyzing
this one of the things that is really
important to us is fast product
development and if you start looking at
the ecosystem of services that are
slowly being built on top of cloud
primitives like instances networking and
storage capacity that's an ecosystem of
services that allows you to move much
faster and deliver a much better product
faster to users think about things like
bigquery or pops-up or data flow those
things are building blocks that allow us
to innovate a lot faster
so let's take a look at where we started
aspetta mark already mentioned we had
everything in on-premise data centers
known for running a large micro surface
architecture at the time we started this
entire process we had about 1200
different micro services that served our
users by now it's several hundred small
and we had a pretty mature engineering
culture around that with lots of
automation around deployments spinning
up instances spinning down instances was
something people could fairly easily do
we ran our service out of four
datacenter sites in the world one on the
west coast one on the east coast of the
US and two in Europe each of those sites
is essentially standalone copy
most of our backend in those data
centers is essentially control playing
of the surface so the content delivery
the music that gets delivered to your
phone and to your desktop or to your
speaker comes out of CDN networks and an
own CDN so it's not coming out of our
data centers that's coming from a
separate place
and we're big on data we're a data
informed company we have about 20,000
data processing jobs 2,000 unique
workflows and about a hundred petabyte
of data when we started and all of that
had to move the clouds now last we had
about a hundred teams and important to
know is probably that those hundred
teams each owned with operational
responsibility for the services they
developed so that means their own call
for those but also own sort of the
entire business problem that they're
trying to solve here's the three main
goals we had with this migration first
link to the first reason we wanted to
minimize disruption to our product
development but you can't stop feature
development for the duration of a cloud
migration because that's completely
unacceptable both to our users and our
stakeholders the second thing we felt
was really important was speed hybrid
states we are in both states are both
expensive that are also risky you force
engineering teams to keep two cognitive
models one for on-premise and one for
cloud and everything you deploy you need
to go through the process of tests work
on cloud this is working on premise if
your incident mode similar problems the
last goal we had was clean up right this
is a forcing function for your long tail
you don't end up with small things that
are still running in the data center and
make sure that you finish but my become
is a big of a surprise to you is that
most of this cloud strategy actually
came from the infrastructure groups the
people maintaining those data centers
building the network building the
instances ingesting all the hardware
those were deeply involved in building
out this cloud strategy and we spend a
lot of time prepping and involving them
in that part of that involvement was
talking about what does your job look
like once we move the cloud but it's to
some degree scary thing to move from a
completely own stack to a cloud and what
are you going to be doing as an
infrastructure engineer we spent a lot
of time talking about how that would
evolve and the net result of that was
that that entire group of engineers
which is some of the most deeply
respected engineers inside Spotify have
a lot
contact with feature teams and often on
the largest-scale core surfaces that we
have another being advocates for a cloud
strategy so we did a big kickoff with
them we build a whole set of prototypes
and during those prototypes we found two
key blockers one blocker was the lack of
PPC when we started which is now there
and available for everyone and the other
problem was related to VPN and we'll
talk about the different in the
different migration tracks we talked
about these two different blockers the
last thing we did was build a minimal
use case and a good one but if you want
to move a multi-million dollar company
you can't show a small prototype you
have to show you you actually can viably
run your business on top of cloud so we
build a minimal working prototype to
played music and was capable of
processing the data coming out to pay
out royalties I think I would like to
spend a little bit of a word on
dependencies I think for every migration
especially for cloud migrations
dependencies are important right if you
look at the micro service typically
servicing an a single customer request
takes about 10 to 15 services and the
same is true for a data processing a
single data processing workflow will
often involve multiple intermediate data
sets and transformation steps across
these stop the world and everybody
migrate is not an option we talked about
that so that means that you need to find
a strategy that allows your teams to
move independently without having to
migrate all their dependencies in one go
as well and this was an important
problem to solve for us in this
migration and with that I'd like to
invite you to mark up here to talk about
some of these strategies
so when we talk about migration to the
cloud in the abstract it breaks down
generally into about two different
strategies the first strategy is lift
and shift that's when you try to keep
your architecture as simple as possible
to whatever you have you minimize your
changes to virtual machines application
layer databases network and so on the
upside of this is that you can focus on
speed and keeping complexity down while
you're migrating the downside is that
you can potentially increase your cost
because your workloads can't really use
the elastic design patterns or higher
level services available in Google Cloud
the other strategy is some form of a
rewrite that's where you're taking some
part of your application or potentially
all of it and completely rewriting it
using more cloud native products and
architectures complexity of this is
basically directly proportional to how
complex is your code base how well does
the development team know it and how
much change are you trying to make to
that application so as max said before
this presentation is divided into two
parts and the first part will cover the
migration of the user facing services
what we're calling the services
migration and the second chapter will
cover the migration of data processing
workloads the data migration services
migration was you use lift and shift
strategy throughout and the data
migration used a hybrid rewrite and lift
and shift approach depending on the kind
of workload that they had and so right
now we're going to dive into the
services migration with Ramon thank you
Hey I'm back so we talked about two
blockers let's dive into them a little
bit the first one was V PC there was no
free PC when we started this it's a new
feature because I build it
collaboratively with Google by soon our
feedback but what we essentially found
was that if you had a microservices in
project the only way for them to talk to
a microservice in project B was for the
request to go essentially out to the
Internet and then come back in and that
they didn't really work that well for us
but we're pretty late-season sensitive
service that was not acceptable we
briefly tried putting our entire
hundred-and-twenty team engineering
organization in one project but that
really didn't work either so we quit
that pretty quickly but we ended up or
what Google ended up stepping up to the
plate and developing was VP C which
allows you to build any similar to an
internal network that connects multiple
of these projects and they can cross
talk easily in that so we ended up with
a decision where we said okay every
services cannot live in a single project
so not every team has a single project
but every service as a single project
and this gives team good control over
their own destiny they get to do the
things that they need to do for their
service in that project and if they
shoot themselves in the foot they're
shooting themselves in the foot but not
the entire company and that's important
to us as well I think the second blocker
that we found in this was VPN when we
started and this is 2015-2016 right we
essentially found we tried connecting
our data centers to Google cloud to
solve the dependency problem so you
could move one service and could connect
to its dependencies in data center that
takes with 1200 Microsoft is quite a lot
of VPN bandwidth and quality on that and
to be honest I think the VPN service at
that time was more or less scaled on
that connect an office with 25
developers in and then we showed up with
4 data centers and multiple 10 thousands
of service that didn't really work that
well again this was a collaboration with
Google when quality was reproof fairly
rapidly and we managed to get this
working solid
so we build several multiple gigabytes
of networked pipes between our different
data centers towards Google Cloud to
allow for that dependency problem to
disappear now after that we spent some
time building just enough infrastructure
to make it actually slightly easier to
spin up capacity in cloud and it was an
on premise slightly faster slightly
easier saying tool yet to set another
key realization in the service migration
is that we could decouple surface
migration from moving our user traffic
170 million plus users generate a lot of
traffic towards our service if you have
to do that full bang in one migration
that's hard you can do the work of
migrating a service to cloud and do the
development work you need for that
without necessarily moving all that
traffic so we deliberately separated
these two with different roadmaps or we
focused on getting all these
applications ready to run in Google
clouds or all these back-end services
and then we had a separate road map that
allowed us to gradually connect more and
more users to with GCP and that allows
us to control both reliability the user
experience and our migration speak and
it allowed us to control how much
traffic was flowing over these PPN links
as well the next thing we did was build
a small migration team there's a hybrid
team staffed out of both Spotify
engineers and Googlers and the first
thing we we did this preparation for
running that migration team was we build
a visualization of the entire migration
State and I'll show that to you in a
second the second thing we did was we
build a completely standardized
migration spring program how do you
migrate back and serviced clouds well
here's a template program on how to do
that we built some teaching material for
common migration cases like how do you
migrate your datastore how do you make
migrated Cassandra how you migrate a
java application and we created a set of
teaching material about Google cloud
what is changing what is important for
you to know
here's how that visualization look so
every bubble is a system the size of the
bubble is proportional to the amount of
machines that the system uses so the
capacity that the system has if it's red
it's in a data center if it's green it's
been migrated to Google cloud and this
had a number of interesting side effects
I think one it saved me is a program
manager a lot of time during status
updates about the state of a migration
because people could just go and look
that was nice but the side effects were
interesting I think what ended up
happening was that several people that
would work in a team and if you look at
the visualization those blueish circles
represent teams and departments so
someone heading up one of these
departments or in a team would go and
hunt for these red bubbles you've got a
quite that not migrated and that was
pretty useful to us the other thing that
it did was that it created a real sense
of accomplishments in teams that were
migrating from the start to this finish
of this migration they could directly
see what impact they were having with
their work ID we updated this more
multiple times a day so literally once
they migrated the system they could see
the bubble go green and that helped a
lot with motivation this is how it
looked by the time we stopped during the
migration with back-end services in May
2017 so we stopped the Sprint program
someone's wondering about the big red
bubble in the middle
that's our dope cluster we did not
migrate that one so starting a spring we
did two things one and this is a really
important one was focus we essentially
did was we negotiated with these
different product departments where was
room in their product roadmap to spend
one or two weeks migrating so they would
not get in trouble with their deadlines
the counter side of that was that we
asked them to stop all other work so no
future work no other things
no minimal things no small things on the
side nothing all the engineers would
focus for the duration of the sprint
only on cloud migration
the second thing we did was in integrity
we covered a number of things one was
what's the mana systems that you own
which ones do you want to migrate are
the ones you don't want to migrate why
and I was a pretty interesting start to
do because in many cases people say well
we're planning to deprecate this anyway
in three months so we can actually speed
that up and do it now
so that is enough many cases is actually
reduced scope instead of increased it
the other thing we looked at was large
data storage systems or if you own
multiple terabytes of data it actually
takes time to transfer that and it's a
bit silly to sit with a whole group of
engineers to wait until transferred to
the other side so often if there were
very large systems we would start that
transfer earlier so we could hit the
ground running wild while starting
sprints the last thing we did was an
operational risk assessment there is a
difference between moving a tier 3
service that does a minimal feature that
the great gracefully for users and a
tier one service that if you [ __ ] it up
the entire service goes down and then
that makes a difference so it's
important to know about that excuse the
language
so with that I would like to ask the two
people that join me in the migration
team to come and talk about this we
split the work in this in three big
blobs and about half of the work was
actual migration work and the
interesting thing was that some of the
feedback we got out of engineers was
that it was boring it actually worked
fairly simple you just redeploy the
application on cloud and it just works
I was really nice too so it took far
less time than we thought it would in
many cases what we did was we asked
people to focus on one region they're
taking production traffic but also spin
minimal capacity up in the other regions
that we were using and then that one
region was taking enough traffic to see
any performance or reliability issues a
key thing was where you get these people
want to fiddle with these systems to
make them better at that time so we were
pretty strict about no we're not
cleaning up tech tip we're migrating at
this time so once the majority of the
systems have been migrated usually by
the end of the first week we would
deliberately in a controlled recorded
way actually induce failures in their
newly migrated systems to see how
comfortable and aware the teams were in
managing incidents so I mean basically
we just started breaking things slowly
until they started noticing and then we
watched and saw and recorded how they
would recover so while it was you know
absolutely fun to break things and watch
teams scramble there were a couple of
interesting things that that came from
that you know the first thing where
there were a couple of obvious ones so
the first one was make sure that the
monitoring systems were properly
extended to the new cloud deployment
make sure that that's all working if we
started breaking something and then the
team didn't notice that was obviously a
big red flag that's something they need
to monitor but I think what was really
interesting was when something broke
team notice recover and we're debriefing
and talking about how we did what we did
or you
what the failure mode was and teams
starting to look into different ways of
monitoring site well you know we noticed
it but if we were monitoring on this
metric instead of that one not only
would we have noticed but we'd have
gotten to the root cause much more
quickly and so that kind of iterative
process over you know deliberately
breaking things really kind of helped a
lot of teams and then finally we had
this playbook that they could start
going to and start building on for
failure modes in the cloud that they may
not have had to deal with before or
encounter before and so that was really
a great experience to kind of watch that
discovery process and kind of build on
that as we went throughout their
migration so we also had for educational
packages and you can see these at the
bottom here I think it's important to
say like we did this for more or less
every team that we encountered so they
had to go through these lectures and
workshops where we discuss different
topics
the first was disappea support and that
was really about how to interact with
support and it was about interacting
with support both during incidents as
well as for a more long-term development
support and it was really important the
small things here like seeing that
people actually created support accounts
and open the case to see how it worked
so when you know in the future they
would have an incident everybody in the
team would feel comfortable interacting
with support the second one was
networking and what we covered here was
really the different semantics of
networking between GCP and on-prem
because the teams were used to operating
on Pam and very specific data centers
the third was a product overview where
we went through most notably the
different database options within DCP
and the goal here was to allow the
different teams to feel comfortable
moving to more manage solutions in the
future now we didn't do this during the
migration itself this was something for
future purposes and last but not least
we also covered costs so that everybody
in the team would feel comfortable
monitoring and understanding the
different semantics of costs on
so as I showed in the visualization by
May we had done on migration Springs
with nearly every team in the company
and at that point even during those
migration spins we slowly started
increasing traffic towards Google Cloud
well we can control where users connect
to more and more users started
connecting it to GCP and during the
migration started gradually increasing
that it allows us to measure and control
the user experience like this was a key
thing for us to make sure that they
continue to be good we have a reputation
for carrying around all the world's
music in your pocket and if you press
play it starts so this user quality was
important for us we wanted to make sure
that that did not degrade for moving to
cloud and this allowed us to measure
that really effectively the other thing
we did was manage reliability risks with
this and the last thing is we were able
to control the amount of users we could
on cloud based on the migration speed
that we had the most services we had in
G speak the more users we managed to
director and then by the time we had all
applications on all services on G speed
we did a number of things while
increasing more and more traffic towards
100% its the reliability program we ran
with individual teams helps teams reason
about their reliability for their system
there is also an aspect of the entire
surface so one of the things we did is
we ran company-wide reliability
exercises where we closed an entire data
center or we closed an entire cloud
reach and then made sure that we could
still provide service to our users just
before Christmas in December last year
2017 we hit 100% users but at that point
the first data center was already closed
we closed our San Jose data center here
on the west coast in October 2017 and
that's a pretty strong signal for people
with long tail applications that are
still running in data centers that they
need to get a move on it was a road map
for the rest we have already closed our
secondary data center in the US
and this to date since left in Europe
which already scaled down significantly
but they'll close by the end of this
year this concludes overview of the
services migration ever now I'd like to
hand over to Josh my colleague to talk
about the data migration exemplary so my
name is Josh Baer I led the data
migration and that's what I'm gonna talk
about right now so just to recap a
little bit about where we were before we
moved our stuff over to GCP we called
ourselves the largest Hadoop cluster in
Europe and we were able to call their
selves that because nobody ever
corrected us so it worked we were
certainly one of the largest clusters
for sure so we had about 20,000 jobs
that ran every day from around 2000
workloads and as Ramon mentioned at the
beginning this was from as many as a
hundred different teams
distributed throughout Europe and the US
so this is a view of what our dependency
graph looks like all those jobs
interacting with each other and this is
actually a vast simplification of our
dependency tree because if we showed the
the full one it would be way too wide
and way too deep to actually project it
and you wouldn't actually see a lot of
it so the crazy thing about this graphic
is each little smudge that you might see
there is a job and each job has an input
and each job has an output and those
inputs are the dependencies and those
dependencies could be from a totally
different team than the team that you
work on and it could be in a different
location than the location you work one
so it was fairly complex try to try to
move these all those jobs over to GCP
without causing downstream failures and
that was really the challenge and that's
overcoming this challenge to raw
strategies what I'm going to talk about
right now so you can now understand the
complexity of what we had to move and
one thing we could have done is to tell
everybody to stop everything they're
doing shut down the Hadoop cluster copy
all the data over to GCP copy the state
and start things back up again
now unfortunately we
do this because as you've seen this
graphics even with 160 gigabit per
second network link that we had to
Google initially it would take us around
2 months to copy all the data that we
had on the cluster and because we're a
business that relies on our data to pay
our labels and we rely on our labels to
fried content and we rely on our content
to provide a service for our users
we wouldn't be much of a business if we
were down for two months so and since
we're and since every noted that the
pendency tree earlier could represent
individuals team we had a rough jobs of
moving things without disrupting other
users so what could we do sorry strategy
was to copy lots of data essentially to
duplicate data both on-premise and on
GCP so as you moved your pipeline as you
moved your job over to GCP what you
would do is you would copy your
dependencies all the data you would set
up a copy job to copy your dependencies
over to DCP and then you could port your
job over then if you had downstream
consumers you might have to copy the
output of your job back to our on
premise cluster so that the downstream
consumers weren't broken and since the
bulk of our data migration lasted around
6 to 12 months we were running a lot of
these jobs to fill gaps in our
dependency trees as you can see in the
graphics here at peak we had 80,000 jobs
that copied data from on-premise to the
cloud and around 30,000 that copied data
back to on-premise so a lot of copies a
lot of duplicate data and a lot of
complexity and I should mention that
these copy jobs were not exactly easy
things to get right so especially early
on we had 160 gigabit per second network
bandwidth and we found problems that
when when jobs were broken and they had
to catch up they would saturate that
network bandwidth and then we had our
high priority jobs that were getting
blocked by maybe jobs that aren't such
high priority so we had to figure out
how to get that working that was one
challenge that we disrupted overtime and
we learned it's it's massively important
in this transition when you're in the
hybrid state to over-provision your
network bandwidth another problem that
we ran into
or another lesson that we learned was to
avoid using the VPN whenever possible in
these copy jobs and fortunately GCS has
application layer security so you really
don't need to use the VPN to copy data
back and forth so while we still
couldn't tell everybody to stop
everything they're doing and and move
everything to the cluster what we could
do is say stop everything new that
you're doing on our on-premise cluster
and start writing all the new things on
TCP and the benefit of that is there's
some natural attrition as people are
rewriting or replacing their jobs
they'll just kill off their old ones on
the on premise but what about the jobs
that already existed and weren't being
replaced so they had two paths to choose
from as was mentioned earlier and that's
what I'm gonna highlight the first path
was called the forklifting path so pure
lifting shift
wouldn't work for us and that and
there's a few reasons for that the first
one is that we really wanted to move
away from this process where we had one
single Hadoop cluster that managed all
our data jobs and one team that managed
that Hadoop cluster that bore all the
operational responsibility if it was up
or down we also wanted to get we also
wanted to adapt to the we also had to
adapt to the assumptions that we made
from on-premise cluster to what the
reality was in TCP so for example our
orchestration framework really depended
on atomic moves and in GCS they don't
have autonomous that same autonomous
City so we had to build some tooling to
bridge that gap so at the start of
migration we actually spent a lot of
time to build infrastructure and tolling
to make it easier for our teams to use
and I want to highlight a few of those
tools that we built in our process and I
should mention that all these are open
source so you can check them out and
maybe they'll be useful to you the first
tool that I want to mention is sticks so
early in our previous on-premise world
we had the concept of these long-lived
edge nodes that launch jobs we wanted to
move to a world where you could just
containerize your job in docker
and use kubernetes to schedule it but we
had to build a scheduler for that and
that's what sticks is so in addition to
being more fault tolerant this process
it allows us to be very flexible across
a cloud and very flexible of with how we
use our resources and we don't have
these these really hand-tuned edged
notes anymore the second tool that I
want to highlight is something called
spydra and in a few words spider is a
new cluster as a service now you might
be thinking there's already a Hadoop
cluster as a service that GCP offers its
data proc right that's true but what we
wanted to do is go one level of
abstraction higher so that our users
really didn't have to worry about
learning a new tool learning how data
proc offers they just write their job
and we take care of the spinning up in
the tearing down of clusters by
ourselves and we take care of a net
tolling centralizing the logging so that
if their job fails they can still figure
out what's wrong with it
so this was great and troubleshooting
was still easy and there was no need for
that centralized infrastructure team and
no need for the centralized big main
Hadoop cluster so the fork lifting path
was primarily the path that teams have
to take if they had a lot of other
priorities and they couldn't couldn't
take the time to rewrite but I'm gonna
talk about the rewriting path now and
that was really evented advantageous for
some other teams so in this path you
would either rewrite your job using
bigquery or a tool called Xie which I'll
talk about a second which is essentially
dataflow so the benefits of this is this
was massively exciting for all our
engineers right one of the real
advantages for moving to GCP is like our
engineers could go and play with the
latest and greatest tech the stuff that
we had read about in papers that we
always had wanted to try out so this was
exciting for them and the benefit for
the teams is this path is actually fully
managed too
so I don't even have to worry about
spinning up and tearing down these
Hadoop clusters we just can outsource
that to to the Google teams to provide
the managed infrastructure for us and
this was also useful for teams that
didn't really feel comfortable
porting over their jobs using the lift
and shift using the fork lifting path
and they might not feel comfortable
because maybe they inherited these data
jobs somewhere in the past and they
never actually had looked at him so I
wanted to dig into him a little bit and
why they were digging to digging into
him it might as well rewrite it so like
the fork lifting path we ended up
creating some tooling to support our
users in this and the main tool that I'd
like to support that's also open source
you should go check it out in github
it's a tool called Sheol Soccio is
essentially a library that's wrapped on
top of beam or data flow which
simplified some of the some of the less
familiar functions of data flow for our
data engineers and it was a bit closer
to scalding something that we use pretty
extensively in our Hadoop world and the
great additional benefit is got real
tight integration with bigquery so if
you just want a few specific columns
that you want to process over you can
use bigquery to get those columns and
then use hewitt to process them so it's
been really successful and I highly
recommend you to check out so but this
path to wasn't without its challenges
the bigger thing the biggest thing is it
required a much larger time investment
from teams right they not just porting
the jobs over there actually rewriting
it and as engineers what usually
happened is when you start to rewrite it
and you say hmm that thing I did what
was I thinking two years ago when I
write that I want to react attack the
two so when teams usually told me they
they would rewrite their jobs in around
two weeks I use it less than a month and
when teams told me it was a month it was
usually three months so that leads into
this this quote here Hofstadter's law it
always took longer even taking it out
that long so towards the middle and end
of our migration we actually had to tell
people to stop to avoid the rewrite path
altogether migrate their stuff using the
forklifting path then if they really did
want to rewrite it rewrite rhe
architecture it was all already on GCP
so we could still hit on migration
targets
so that's our strategy I want to quickly
highlight the tactics that we use to
move teams over to so at this point we
provided the tooling for our for the
teams to forklift their jobs over and we
provided libraries that they could use
to rewrite their jobs on GCP natively
but for other teams the reality was
still that ramping up to speed with
these new tools was a challenge there
were new things and they didn't really
have capacity to learn new things or
maybe they had specific edge cases that
the tools didn't cover so to solve that
we decided to create a temporary team
temporary teams can pose of both
infrastructure engineers and the feature
teams the people that understood the
business logic so the benefit of having
an infrastructure engineers is they're
the people that created their tools so
you understand really well how to to
adapt jobs to get them to run on GCP and
the benefit of having the the feature
teams work on it as they understood the
business logic and they were especially
important because they would own the
jobs when it when it's on GCP and they
would have to understand how how their
logic worked so these task force lasted
around one to two weeks of highly
focused Sprint's with one main goal and
that was to take all your jobs port them
over to GCP and oh yet don't break your
downstream consumers use those copy jobs
so now that was that was a tactics and
strategy I'm gonna quickly highlight
what our data stack looks like now on
top of GCP so the first tool that I'd
like to highlight is bigquery and maybe
some of you saw nicole's in the audience
over there to a talk yesterday we're on
how we we use bigquery at Spotify this
really like when we started seeing
bigquery use it really underscores a
powerful explosion and being in lowering
the friction for asking and answered
questions and how adoption really
increased as you see now we have around
25% of our Spotify as employees use
bigquery and before the migration I
think we had around 50 monthly active
users for hive that were asking and
answering jobs using that ad hoc another
tool that I would like the highlight is
pub sub so pub sub feeds both our
and our real-time data processing jobs
and the great thing about pub/sub is
it's significantly lowered our
operational costs from before the
migration then I'd like to highlight
both data flow in and data proc so we're
heavily heavy users of both data flow in
particular I think a few months ago I
talked to the PM and we were the largest
dataflow user I think we're still at
least one of the largest now we run them
around four five thousand jobs per day
and almost all these jobs are using
sheíll which is our engineers absolutely
love to use so you might be thinking
what happened to Europe's largest Hadoop
cluster right what do we do with that so
at the end of q1 this year we held a big
gathering in our Stockholm office in the
cafeteria on the top floor and we had
one of the first engineers that ran a
Hadoop job at Spotify press a big red
button shutting down the power and our
London data center that that gave that
was our Hadoop cluster and the crowd sat
there and watched a live feed of our
data center and the first thing they
noticed is all this whirring and buzzing
of fans in the data center immediately
like when silent and it was crazy and
then one by one you see all these
blinking lights stopped to blink and
shut down and go dark and that really
signaled the end of our life as an
on-premise Hadoop user and signaled the
start of our life as fully native on GCP
and the complete that day's celebration
we had an office space styled
dismantling of one of our name nodes
that was used early on and as you could
see there to really just let the steam
out and in signal that transition yeah
so that can include the the migration we
want to highlight bring everybody on
stage and highlight a few of the most
important lessons that we learned
throughout the process
[Applause]
[Music]
great so the first lesson is prepare and
I think it's important to state here
that we prepared for probably two years
before actually doing the migration and
each migration took roughly a year so we
spent a lot of time preparing right now
what we really did was we tried as you
can see here are a minimal use case that
showed the benefits of moving to GCP but
when we say minimal here it's important
to say that it wasn't a small thing it
had to been an important feature for the
entire business to show the true value
of moving over for each of these minimal
use cases we refined the model for
moving over so over time it became
better and better
one thing that's also important to note
is that you're early adopters if you
decide to do this are super important
because they will be your developer
advocates later on in the organization
as your migration progressed great that
was the first lesson prepare I'll take
the second lesson the second lesson is
focus it is truly amazing what you can
do with a team of engineers if you focus
on single thing we literally had
Sprint's that last of the week where we
moved more than 50 to 70 services it is
amazing do that it helps a lot it will
also help your business stakeholders
there'll be a lot happier that there's a
short period of time that there's no
product development instead of an
extended period of time you should try
doing migrating while doing all the
other priorities that you have within
the business your migration speed will
slow to a crawl and that you make this a
far more difficult process than it has
to be
the third lesson is creating a migration
team both of the two different paths of
services and data migration use a
migration team to help enable the teams
actually doing the migrating in
accelerate that process and the way we
looked at it was to go into teams and
act as guardrails for them the teams
that maintain the services know the code
better know the services better than we
do but we came in and said you know what
we're here to make sure that you know
you know what you need to know we can
pass on past experience past learnings
and make this as efficient as possible
we're here to be resources that you need
whether you need to talk about you know
new libraries that you're doing data
migration or maybe talk to somebody at
Google because we were curious about how
something else works and what was great
about that is that we got to carry the
experience from each migration from team
to team to team so you're not doing say
five teams migrating in isolation team
one and Team four run across the same
roadblock and spend the same amount of
time solving the same problem well what
we could do is take that experience and
carry it forward carry it throughout and
so each sequential migration actually
improves on the previous in terms of
what we could carry through and so that
was very very helpful on both sides of
those migrations to be able to move
those teams forward and the last lesson
that we wanted to highlight was to get
out of hybrid as fast as you can so in
the data migration as we mentioned all
these copy jobs back and forth to a
clusters was both expensive in terms of
like network bandwidth but also complex
in terms of people had to figure out
where the jobs were actually running and
where the dependencies were it was also
a problem in the services as Ramon
highlighted early on so when you were in
an incident mode you had to figure out
where is the problem is it in the on
premise tooling is it in the GCP tooling
or maybe is it in the glue in between
yeah and this also as Ramon mentioned as
cognitive overhead for your teams and
when you want to focus on the world just
purely on the cloud that's not something
you want to think of so if you move to
the cloud as fast as possible you just
folk
I'm being cloud native so that concludes
the presentation will now take questions
I think using the mics on the side thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]